♪♪
Neil:
I didn't want to write an
unhappy marriage.
But all marriages involve
different kinds of tension
different kinds of compromise
Neil:
different world views.
And so what I wanted to do was
look at the thematic fault-lines
Neil:
running through their
philosophies.
Let's be clear, it's not me,
it's you killing this woman!
What do you want me to say?
Neil:
There's some level of assumption
that Margot is
Neil:
in some way along for the ride.
(Gunshot)
Neil:
In that moment in this
episode...
(Heavy breathing)
Neil:
.... we get the first real solid
glimmer
that things might be otherwise.
Melissa:
When you get told something
there's a gun at the back
wife's head
Melissa:
and you actually don't care
well that's what she thinks
Allie was going through.
Melissa:
She's had enough.
That's when she realizes that
she's gotta take the kids.
Melissa:
And life with Allie is not worth
it.
Margot:
You promise and promise but
never deliver.
Margot:
That's my fault.
But that's not happening
anymore.
♪♪
That's over.
Rupert:
There's always a compelling
story to be told
when you're telling the story of
people who love each other
Rupert:
but find it hard to coexist.
And when that actually then gets
to the stakes of Life and Death.
Rupert:
I think it makes for
great drama.
For Margot and Allie I said
"Well is this a romantic
couple?"
We've had long conversations of
whether they are even in love
anymore.
Justin:
For so long it's been
function of just survival.
They both take turns using
different limbs to try and wrap
their arms around their family.
Justin:
And I think they have an
intuitive knowledge
Justin:
on how to do it.
Margot's main priority is the
family.
Gabriel:
And Melissa, I think, really
brings out the motherly aspect.
She's like that on set all the
time, she's just very kind and
caring.
Whispering:
Don't! Get down!
The cops are coming.
Rupert:
Justin and Melissa, they created
a real bond.
You know they really
work together immensely well.
Melissa:
Working with Justin is
just incredible.
He's so great to just like throw
ideas off.
Logan:
He did a really great job
at just making
everyone multi-dimensional so
that there was a lot of just
subtext going on.
And there would be a look between
Allie and Margot
Melissa:
and you know, without even
speaking, that the two
Melissa:
of them know exactly what to do
in order to get them
Melissa:
out of the situation.
Margot:
Lock yourself in the bathroom.
Their bond and their love is
really through the conduit of
their children.
Justin:
And I wonder if anything ever,
God forbid, happened to their
Justin:
children whether they would even
stay together
Justin:
or whether there would be a
purpose to.
♪♪